hello
is this steve yes steve how are you
mr patrick how are you my friend i am
doing very good so steve so you said you
were in the israel army for eight years
yeah i'm the one that sent you the the
toys for your family
every christmas oh man you're so amazing
i appreciate that brother thank you so
much for doing that the kids appreciate
it as well
i appreciate it thank you so so tell us
what do you think about what's going on
with israel and palestine you were in
the israeli army for
eight years obviously this is a very
very uh heated debate on debate on both
sides folks from palestine have strong
opinions folks from israel have strong
opinions what are your thoughts about
what happened there
okay my thought is the fact you know i'm
sorry my english is not the best but
i've been there for
i lived there for 35 years now i live in
orlando
but i was there for eight years people
doesn't understand i hate when people
say they see the news and they say oh
free palestine free israel people have
no clue what's going on
we're treating the arab better than
anyone else if hamas
will literally control the gaza and they
will take over whatever the dream to
take over israel yeah the arab will
suffer like nobody ever understand that
people don't understand how we give we
give them water electric they work with
us i actually know their language i work
with them i have millions afraid arabs
and they even understand that the
israeli arabs especially they understand
what's going on
if the hamas will take over they are
done they treat them they beat them in
the street they do whatever they want
you cannot go without
you know they cover on the head they
will beat you you cannot
it's like they're gonna make it like
iran which you know better than anyone
people don't understand how moral i
never hit no arabs for no reason i never
shot no one for no reason
people doesn't understand what's going
on there they're all about blood
they're going behind school the shooting
so we can shoot the kids and they can
show it in cnn
it's unbelievable what's going on
unbelievable i'm like i'm in shock
people just throwing memes and social
media free palestine
they have no clue what's going on are
you saying that the hamas believes in
sharia law
100 okay 100
continue did you have a follow-up i just
wanted to see if that's what he was
trying to say
and by the way can you unpack that
unpack that for
us and the listeners okay so
so for example if you go now to let's
say
gaza or jericho or whatever okay yeah
and uh
just for example you're gonna ask a
father with four kids
let's say you have two boys and two
girls you ask them how many kids you
have you know what i will say
what two they will never say four
they don't count the girls they treat
them like garbage
the treatment just to clean the house to
have babies and that's it
they don't have a state they don't have
a war they don't have nothing people
don't get it
they believe in sharia because also
that's how they take the taxes that's
how they take their money
and people that need i was in gaza just
gaza for one year and eight months
i was four months of them undercover
what i feel there is unbelievable they
hate they have the blood
steve do you mind do you mind if i
three-way anasan who is on the complete
opposite side because he's got some
strong opinions
and see if the rest of us can just
listen to the two of you guys uh have a
discourse is that okay with you
okay honest i'm about to call you folks
hang tight i'm trying to get on asan
uh give me a second here anas thank you
for your patience let me see if i got
the number 1929
all right two three one six three oh
eight here we go
and who is that now exactly i don't know
who anas is
i don't know who nas is uh anas is got
the complete opposite opinion
okay then when steve has anas can you
hear us
yes i'm doing wonderful i appreciate you
i'm on a three-way you went hang tight
for me did you hear the comments steve
made
yes okay so hang on before you bring in
steve anas give us your bio
wait let me bring steve because it
doesn't matter they got to know each
other anyway
so uh uh so at this point we know
steve's background is he was in the
israeli army for atf
so so so steve can you take 30 seconds
and give us your background once again
you said eight years
in the israeli army tell us a little bit
more again
okay yeah i was eight years i joined
army when i was 18. in israel you have
to be
three years in the army but i signed
more than i become an officer for eight
years
i was almost two years in gaza and the
rest on ramallah all the arab area
i was a commander 450 soldiers
and i can guarantee you that we are the
most
moral army ever we give them food
we give them everything we treat them
good they're working with us
and perfect on us can you give us your
back steve thank you for that honest
give us your background before you guys
can go into
i'm palestinian i was born in this
country i was raised in palestine for a
year
so unfortunately your guest i think he's
kind of misinformed
about a few things so number one so
number one
i'm gonna be respectful here because he
was respectful so i'm gonna be
respectful for example we treat our
daughters and sons the same way
my family have a lot of daughters in our
family and my uncle he says that he
likes his daughters more than his
sons so i think that he has to talk
about those things number one but number
two i want to
say something important patrick is that
as a palestinian as a muslim for
as a muslim i condemn killing civilians
because in islam we're not allowed to
kill civilians it's in the sharia law
if someone's one could read the shri
allah it says in islam they're not
allowed to kill civilians no matter what
and i want to tell this young man here
this gentleman here because you know
he's a good man he's educated i hope
is that uh the palestinians they elected
hamas because there was elections in
palestine there was no elections
recently because
israel and the american government and
the the federal party doesn't want to
allow for
elections and if you look at the last
four cause we say that israel is the
most small army in the world
how many kids died now like i don't care
if it's an israeli kid or palestinian
kid
a lot of kids died you know how many
kids got trauma
and they say oh how much they took the
rockies that's dark side can you see the
evidence police i've been asking the
israeli you know
media and army to show us the evidence
that if there's rockets in the buildings
show but no they didn't show it they
just use the
the planes to punish the palestinians
for voting for hamas
because they can't get to hamas they're
fighting face to face if israel wants to
really destroy hamas go into gaza go
into gaza and be madness
1915. many armenians were taken in by
palestinian lebanese and syrian families
you took the armenians in
and and we have to be you know straight
here israel's was built
on palestine 531 villages was destroyed
11 cities was destroyed
tiberius all these cities are in today
israel
were once part of palestine and the
palestinians were living there
and they were kicked out of their lands
and this whole conflict
started when the israeli army quote
unquote the most small army in the world
stormed islam's third holy site can you
imagine if a muslim army
stormed the vatican or stormed orthodox
christian church
how would the world react can you
imagine how would the world react
the turkish army stormed the orthodox or
greek church
and they desecrated it so let's be uh
straight here let's be
uh balanced here now i'm gonna say on
tape
if hamas killed civilians i condemned
that 100 percent
i condem killing civilians 100 percent
because the rockets that they have
because iran provides some weapons but
these rockets are not
what you might call it they're not
accurate and plus hamas warned them
twice they say if you keep touching and
evict palestinians from their houses
we're going to respond and israel didn't
heed the warning and hamas responded
now me i'm
there are many smart there are many
smart palestinians in this world
that are engineers lawyers filmmakers
all this stuff and they can't
go with the full potential because
israel is putting a blockade on gaza
we're not allowed to have our own
businesses in our own state pack
but let me ask a question if new york or
los angeles was under a blockade
because because the people chose donald
trump and russia and china put america
under blockade and they
counted the calories that came in this
country how would america react
if someone came to your houseplant and
said this is my house
and it's my house and because god said
how would you react
this is you have the right america gave
you a second amendment right to defend
yourself
the palestinians are practicing the
rights that god gave them that allah
gave them
the second amendment rights to defend
their land
defend the west bank defend our holy
sites okay
and and it's clear let me be very clear
about something if anybody
in america attacks a jew for no reason
even if
he's from my own people even he's an
arab or a muslim i will beat the crap
out of him and defend that jews writes
because i'm i'm a muslim father i got to
say something i got to say something we
got lucky here but
uh steve i'm going to come to you in a
second folks if you're listening in
we are probably the luckiest people to
have gotten this to
because you're both sounding obviously
there's some emotion behind you but
you're both being reasonable and
respectful to one another
i appreciate that that's the
valuetainment type of style steve i want
to hear your response to what anas just
said
yeah yeah go ahead steve sorry okay
first of all i think is that you talking
about misinform
hey i don't know where you from in
palestine which area you call west bank
west bank yeah i think there are many
here but
when you say arab doesn't just for
example if israel were very mean like
everybody try to
we can operate palestine in a second
we try never to shoot we're telling
everybody where the hamas
you know if i got forbid shooting let's
say i have 20 kids around me
and i will shoot your house you wouldn't
say oh there is
behind steve i'm not going to shoot him
you will freaking shoot me as much as
you can to protect your kids
so when they're going to kindergarten
and everything and they're shooting us
don't think that we're going to say oh
wait what are we going to do there is
kids because that's
it's 99 vote for hamas because that's
how it's going to work
and fatah was supposed to come now to
election and that's why
whatever his name is whatever he did
because yeah because he wanted to he
didn't want to have election because he
will be lose 100 percent you will lose
that's right
i agree with you that's what he did that
is a distraction like
a lot of politicians yes you know that's
patrick what's ironic tell me
that all the leaders the hamas selling
all the kids to die you think i care
about i don't care about kids dying yeah
but you know where they are they're all
in vegas they're all in dubai they're
not even there they're just saying
go die for palestine go up on their bus
brother with all the respect the leaders
of hanas are in gaza right now as we
speak
i assure you i bet you one million
dollars
well listen gentlemen i appreciate you
for your time this was great here's what
we're doing
i have a youtube channel we talk about
issues all the time why don't you put
the link in the description
put it in the description the audience
if they want it they can follow here's
what i'm going to be doing for both of
you guys gang if you watch this and you
enjoyed
steven and us click that subscribe
button steve you gave us
99 bucks and 99 cents i'm giving you 10
times back you're getting a thousand
dollars for uh doing what you
perspective folks if you loved this
smash the thumbs up on that i thought
that was class act and
give a uh steven and us uh some love uh
on the commentary
we're probably gonna bring those guys
back the way they give us their update
we're probably gonna bring
bring them back okay any take away from
you i think that's what valuetainment's
all about
two reasonable people with polar
opposite perspectives having a
conversation and you being the moderator
and us
all listening and hearing what the
perspectives were i got to give it up to
steve and abbas what was his name
anas anas uh total respect
and you have someone who's palestinian
who had a perspective
he said he's american so maybe he didn't
really spend a lot of time in gaza
one year he said one year yeah and you
have somebody who's
spent years thirty-five years in the
military i speak
the language i will say there is a big
difference between the west bank
yes near jerusalem versus gaza which is
the question
okay exactly and uh uh
uh gaza is a lot worse on the west bank
and i will say on behalf of
uh steve said this he said we could
annihilate the palestinians if we wanted
to in one second which is true
which is true i sent you something about
that i don't know if you saw what uh
yeah
israel has the most powerful army this
tiny little country the size of delaware
has the most powerful
army in the entire middle east more per
capita more powerful than iran
more powerful than saudi arabia they
could destroy palestine they could
but they don't on on the on the flip
side
they do have a moral obligation israel
being a
democracy people that believe they try
to be a shining light in a city of a
hill like much like america
yeah in the middle east they do have a
moral obligation
to humanize the people of gaza
steve steve said um that they do not
hold free and fair elections i agree
with that i do agree that
that uh especially in the west bank
mahmoud abbas has been uh there for 15
years he has not had to face a
re-election
there's a lot of corruption going on
especially in gaza
a lot of corruption but israel being the
shining light in the middle
east should do their best to have moral
authority over it
here's where i come out with steve that
perspective was unbelievable somebody
else
is going to be back unbelievable they're
going to be bad you know and here i'll
say this you know
i love all people that are peace right i
think most people are in that
camp i like palestinians i love israelis
the whole thing
the wild card here is hamas right and i
think if you listen to steve that's what
he's talking about this is a terrorist
faction
that that fights very very unfairly and
dirty and that's who you know is causing
most of the problem i
i think palestinians and israelis could
live
you know a little bit more peacefully
than people give them credit for but
when you have the wild card factor like
hamas
and that's where you hear the the
passion and it really coming in because
they
when you see the stuff probably that
steve's seen and he hasn't told us you
know probably yet a fraction of what he
knows
but it's unbelievable when you get uh
the perspective from somebody on the
ground
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye